ustedes escucharán y verán que se hace
mucha referencia en computación a los
diagramas de flujo y en realidad cuando
la gente habla de diagramas de flujo se
puede estar refiriendo a cualquier tipo
de algoritmo o proceso creo que debería
escribir un diagrama de flujo simple
para cada uno de los programas que hago
tal vez no lo haré para todos pero
empezaré con uno básico para que
entiendan que un diagrama de flujo no es
nada complicado regresemos a este
programa de factorial que hemos estado
revisando en los últimos vídeos cada
diagrama de flujo tiene un punto de
inicio que se representa con un círculo
como este inicio así que empieza en la
línea de aquí arriba antes de asignar a
la variable número lo que el usuario
teclea después mediante la función input
pedimos al usuario que teclee un número
y representaremos esto mediante un
paralelogramo y podríamos decir aquí
número igual a entrada del usuario
y pueden ser un poco flexibles con la
terminología que usen aquí lo importante
es dar entender qué es lo que se hace en
este paso el paralelogramo nos indica
que tenemos alguna interacción con el
usuario puede ser que le pidamos algún
dato o que le demos algún resultado así
que aquí le pedimos al usuario que nos
dé un número y lo asignamos a la
variable número lo siguiente que haremos
es una operación hacemos producto igual
a 1 y esto lo haremos en un rectángulo
producto es igual a uno y luego va a
pasar algo interesante entramos en
nuestro ciclo ford y empezamos
escribiendo algo diferente a lo que
hemos visto acá vamos a empezar nuestro
ciclo ford con una asignación en un
ciclo for realmente pasan un montón de
cosas al mismo tiempo asignamos a la
variable y el primer número de esta
secuencia o mejor dicho intenta asignar
un elemento de la secuencia a la
variable i y si logra hacerlo continúa
con el ciclo y si no lo logra entonces
sale del ciclo así que voy a ponerlo de
esta manera voy a dibujar un rombo en el
que tendremos los elementos restantes de
la secuencia
elementos restantes de la secuencia y
cuando digo secuencia me estoy
refiriendo a esta secuencia la que se
genera mediante la función range de
número y que en el ejemplo que vimos en
el vídeo anterior el número era 3
entonces los elementos de la secuencia
son estos de aquí y decimos hay
elementos restantes en la secuencia si
todavía quedan elementos por asignar
aquí decimos si hacemos y igual al
siguiente elemento de la secuencia si ya
no quedan elementos bueno eso lo veremos
en un momento continuemos por acá
suponiendo que hay elementos por asignar
a la variable y esta es una operación
asignar a la variable y el siguiente
elemento de la secuencia dibujamos un
rectángulo porque la asignación es una
operación y hacemos y es igual al
siguiente elemento de la secuencia
y luego también vamos a definir producto
redefinimos producto como el valor
anterior de producto por y más uno
también esta redefinición es una
operación que ponemos en un rectángulo
producto es igual a producto al valor
anterior del producto por y más uno
y en este punto esencialmente regresamos
al ciclo regresamos al ciclo y volvemos
a revisar si hay elementos restantes por
eso se llama ciclo porque regresamos a
las mismas instrucciones regresamos a
preguntar si hay más elementos con los
que se ejecutarán las instrucciones del
ciclo regresamos al principio y
preguntamos hay más elementos en la
secuencia y debería haber un signo de
interrogación aquí porque es una especie
de decisión que especificamos con este
rombo si hay más elementos en la
secuencia entonces y es igual al
siguiente elemento por asignar y
producto es igual a producto por y más
uno y volvemos una vez más a la pregunta
hay más elementos en la secuencia y
llegará el punto en que no habrá más
elementos por asignar en la secuencia
entonces el ciclo se rompe salimos del
ciclo for y la siguiente cosa que
hacemos después de que salimos del ciclo
es imprimir el valor de producto
mostramos el valor del producto al
usuario y esto es una interacción con el
usuario imprimimos el valor del producto
imprimir producto y hemos terminado y
ponemos el fin de nuestro programa aquí
el programa terminará de correr
fin este es un diagrama de flujo simple
para este programa simple espero que
puedan entender un poco más cómo
funciona el programa que hemos estado
revisando y también que puedan entender
cómo funciona un diagrama de flujo